in today's world you can get your news  from social media sites like Twitter and  Instagram especially if you follow the  right people anyone following actor Sean  Fantino the guy who played Franklin and  grand theft auto 5 got quite a teaser  recently this instagram photo shows the  voice actor in a full motion capture  suit sitting in what appears to be rock  stars opposite it's similar to a photo  he posted back in June with pictures  like that people are going to speculate  and the common theory is that fonteno is  in the studio working on the rumour GTA  5 single player expansion it's certainly  plausible though we'll have to wait  until Rockstar officially announces any  new content it won't be the first time  GTA has received single-player DLC GTA 4  is lost in the Damned and the ballad of  gay tony were well received on the last  console generation whatever Rockstar  brings to GTA 5 you can be sure you'll  hear about it on gamespot